we didn't have a great experience of  meeting president trump  um sadly we had a nasty trick played on  us and that's left us with some  pretty deep emotional scars sadly  but i would definitely welcome the  opportunity to meet  with president biden you know i'd i take  the opportunity to remind him that  the uk and the us are the strongest  allies in the world  and the us shouldn't have treated the uk  in this way at all  he's still got the opportunity to to put  the wrong right he's still got the  opportunity to make sure that ann  secular stands trial  in this country i'm looking forward to  the day that i can  wake up and just be  a mom to nile and a wife to bruce  and not have to  continually fight this war  that i feel that i'm in